all right so I got to talk about the
latest absolute madness from Isis it
seems like it can't get worse with them
and just every horrific thing that they
do it seems like this is the worst well
then of course it always gets worse the
most recent of course is the captured
Jordanian pilot they burned him alive
in a cage literally burned him alive in
a cage the video of this pretty much has
disappeared off the internet probably
for good reasons we don't need to give
these guys any extra propaganda they say
that every time these videos come out
there that it actually helps their
recruiting which I know that sounds
completely insane because it's so awful
yet human psychology is an odd thing
anyway people that did see it reputable
reporters and things said that this was
just about the worst thing that you can
possibly imagine now in retaliation
Jordan has executed a couple Isis
hostages that they had and now the
question is and this is what it's going
to be about with Isis is what do we do
next what does everyone do doesn't look
everyone looks at America they hate
America when we do anything right and we
go over there and we muck up a lot of
things and we start the wrong wars and
we help people that we end up arming the
wrong people and all that stuff and yet
if we don't do anything nothing good
seems happen there are plenty of other
countries that are right there with big
armies Turkey Saudi Arabia etc Jordan
has an army that was there pilot that
was flying over that got shot down and
now killed so this is such an odd
discussion to have because we don't have
it often enough what is the real role of
the United States and what is the role
of these other countries that are on the
borders with Syria that are on the
borders with Iraq what is their role to
contain this thing because we keep
hearing from our president that it
sounds like in the State of the Union
two weeks ago sounds like we're making
some headway with them kobani fell so we
got that back yet on the other hand it
sounds like it's just getting worse and
then when you look there with the
Japanese hostages two weeks ago both had
never dead it turns out the Jordanian
one that they had killed him a month ago
and over the last couple weeks they were
negotiating over trying to get some of
their people back butchers well [ __ ]
you can't negotiate with these people
clearly and we're operating on two
different we live in a civil society and
they're living just in a completely
barbaric place I don't know what the
answers are Tandy
but I think we really have to have a
mature discussion about what we should
do what our role is and what the world's
role is in stopping something that is
just absolutely awful